If your country was under attack
by a giant radioactive monster, what would you do?
Tokyo is about to be destroyed,
and your government
is responsible
for stopping the creature in its tracks.
I'm going to break down the mistakes
made, what you should do,
and how to beat Godzilla in Shin Godzilla.
This country is about to face a crisis
like never before.
The Coast Guard spot a stranded yacht
floating in Tokyo Bay.
Finding only some personal effects. They wonder
if someone fell off the yacht and drowned.
Suddenly the sea erupts from below
and massive amounts
of blood bursts into this underwater highway.
The government arranges a meeting to discuss
what just happened, and they see on the news
what looks to be a volcanic eruption at Tokyo Bay,
forcing people to evacuate.
The government
runs through a list of possibilities,
including the idea of a new volcano.
But one official interrupts
to say that the bay is too shallow for a volcano.
Yaguchi here tells the others
that their theories are all wrong.
There's something in that bay.
They move operations into a conference room as
more and more civilians keep evacuating the area.
Suddenly, the government gets word
that eruption activity is dying down.
But Yaguchi here calls B.S.
on that and says that a massive creature could be
behind all of this, but no one believes him.
They watch another broadcast and see a giant tail
come out of the ocean.
The government is split
between wanting to kill this creature
as soon as possible or capture it for research.
This lady analyzes the video and thinks
that it may be capable of walking on land.
The government then decides to tell the world,
according to experts, it cannot come onto land.
It would crush itself under its own weight
and tells the world to remain calm.
But that's when this thing
now destroying anything on either side of the
Nomi River gets out of the water and on to land,
wreaking havoc in the city
and thousands of people run for their lives.
OK, the government was way too calm
about everything leading up to this
but if you think about it, their calm
reaction to the events
leading up to this actually makes sense. Why?
Japan is one of the few countries located above
what is called the Ring of Fire.
Or the Circum Pacific Belt.
It's a path along the Pacific Ocean that traces
the boundaries between several tectonic plates.
75% of the Earth's volcanoes,
more than 450 of them are located along this area.
A large portion of the planet's
most violent acts happen here.
Japan is no slouch
when it comes to dealing with natural disasters.
Since the archipelago is situated
along this ring of fire.
This country is vulnerable to natural disasters
such as earthquakes, tsunamis
and volcanic eruptions in fact.
Japan is so used to all of this that it even has
a dedicated budget and massive systems in place
to deal with all of this.
They've earthquake resistant buildings
that move with the earthquakes,
which means that everything
these guys have experienced up to
this point was pretty much
just another regular Tuesday,
minus the giant, ugly
monster crushing its way through the city streets.
And ruining people's lives.
The creature going through tiny streets
tramples everything in its path,
going at a pace of eight miles an hour,
giving the government only 3 hours
until it reaches Tokyo City.
The government in an emergency meeting
quickly works on a plan.
They talk about a military strike,
but the area is too densely
populated for them to use any heavy artillery.
They then argue about the steps
it would take to move everyone out of the area,
knowing it would result in a massive gridlock,
leaving tens of thousands of terrified
people trapped with little choice.
They decide to go ahead with the evacuation,
arranging
for emergency personnel
to help people escape on foot.
The giant creature climbs onto an apartment,
tips it over and kills everyone inside
The government watches the entire thing
play out and realizes that it's now or never.
They authorize four defense forces
to attack the creature head
on, even while thousands of citizens
are fleeing the area
and they need the final attack order
from the prime minister.
Government officials tell the prime minister that
he needs to take action now or it'll be too late.
Military attack helicopters are sent off
and the government officials
pat themselves on the back
for taking care of the threat.
Meanwhile, the creature stops, gets on its back
legs and collapses, sending debris and dust
all over. Everyone freezes,
not knowing what is going to happen next.
Suddenly it stands back up and begins
evolving rapidly, gaining
size and turning into a much deadlier creature
and into Japan's greatest enemy, Godzilla.
Now it begins walking through the city
at a much faster pace.
And that's when the military arrives on the scene,
taking possession
to gun down this deadly creature once and for all.
They ready their guns to fire,
but notice civilians still evacuating the city.
The prime minister gives them orders
to hold off their attack
in order to ensure the safety
of the remaining escapees.
But that was his biggest mistake.
Godzilla sprints through the buildings
and head straight back into Tokyo Bay.
The government officials visit
the disaster zone, shocked at the amount of damage
caused in only 2 hours.
They worry that the creature is hiding in the bay
and is going to make another appearance
very soon. Should have made your move
when it was just crawling on the ground.
Now we have to decide
if using munitions against Godzilla
is worth human lives and the long term effects.
If we don't up front
cost of life that we put in harm's way versus
the millions of lives that Godzilla will kill,
the longer it remains alive.
We have no way of knowing yet
if our weapons will work against Godzilla.
And the last thing we want to do is pass it off.
But what choice do we have?
We got to do something.
And we're lucky
that Godzilla wasn't able to stay on land
many sea creatures are often
crushed by their own weight
if they even attempt to make land,
including mammals such as whales.
And Godzilla, it seems, is no exception.
This is evident as there is little reason
that Godzilla would have returned to see
if it didn't have to, since it was met
with basically no resistance when it made land.
It is being driven exclusively by instinct
meaning it didn't go back into the sea
because it was bored.
It went back because it had to.
We need to assume it's coming back
and we need to get a move on getting ready for it.
If I was there, I would quickly get over the fact
that countless lives will die.
But if we want our kids
to have a home to return to, we have no choice.
And the fact that they only used Kawasaki H one
Ninja Scout helicopters to take it on is insane.
Yaguchi arranges an informal meeting and gathers
experts of every discipline to add their $0.02
and regards to the apocalyptic threat at hand.
They look at the three mutations of the creature,
thinking there's more to come.
However, they can't get a good read on it
with the limited information they have.
They want to know what kind of energy source
could fuel a creature this big.
This lady
doctor suggests that Godzilla might be using
nuclear energy to power its gargantuan frame.
They begin analysis of the creature's path
throughout the city and notice
that it's left a path of radiation
wherever it went.
That's when the U.S.
deputy chief's aide requests a meeting
with Yaguchi, the deputy chief's aide.
Kayoko strikes a deal with the Yaguchi
and asks him to find a Japanese professor
who knew that Godzilla was going to attack years
before it ever happened.
She wants them to hand over the professor
in exchange for U.S.
intel on the creature.
Later, the government informs her
that the professor's boat
was found missing a few days ago
and hands over the intel
that they recovered from the ship in exchange
The lady hands over her intel on Godzilla.
They analyze the intel that Kayoko gave them,
looking at classified photos
showing the mass dumping of radioactive materials
into the ocean.
The lady confirms
that this is what the creature fed on
to become the giant behemoth they see today.
The experts discuss their new findings,
discovering that
Godzilla is capable of self mutation, making it
an increasingly powerful force to reckon with.
However, the creature is mortal
and it can be killed.
One of the experts question
why it returned to Tokyo Bay.
And this bald man has a realization.
This creature has a biological nuclear
reactor in its body
and it needs to return to the bay
in order to cool off. This is beyond bad.
We've got a prehistoric creature
that powers itself by feeding a nuclear waste.
And radiation
usually isn't too nice to biological matter.
It's helped with advances
in medicine, academics, agriculture, archeology
like carbon dating, geology, and even more.
But all the same, radiation is scary
because radiation is basically
the emission of energy in the form of waves
or particles through space
or through a material medium like radium,
a naturally occurring radioactive metal.
This stuff at high doses has the ability to damage
DNA in our cells, causing a bunch of horrifying
stuff to happen within the body mutagenic effects,
cellular degradation, and even organ failure.
Like, seriously,
don't hype up radiation poisoning on Google.
This stuff is so volatile.
The human species, along with every other species,
consists of trillions of cells.
Godzilla getting power from radiation
means that every single one
of his trillions of cells within
his body would have had to mutate
to the exact same way, which is highly unlikely.
Exhausted.
Yaguchi takes a nap, but his subordinate rushes in
and says that Godzilla is back.
The massive creature rises from the ocean
and makes its way back onto land,
destroying homes, businesses,
everything in its path.
Causing horrified civilians to run.
The government watches from the meeting room
and realizes something extremely worrying.
The creature has nearly doubled in size.
The analytic still projected that Godzilla
will reach Tokyo metropolitan area in 3 hours.
And the government officials fear
that it might be headed towards
a nuclear facility on the way,
which would result in a large scale
massive disaster
that would last decades crippling the country.
Great. Just great. Now
it wants a nuclear snack for dessert.
Japan is no slouch
when it comes to nuclear energy.
This type of energy usage
has been a national priority for them since 1973.
And in fact from 1970 onwards,
Japan has only quadrupled their nuclear power
capacity to the point where up until 2011 Japan
was generating some 30% of electricity
from its reactors, with plans to only increase
until the Fukushima accident, of course,
which kind of throw a wrench into that plan.
As of 20, 22, Japan has 33
nuclear power reactors classed as operable,
meaning that Godzilla has plenty to choose from.
This animal is driven by instinct
unless we can find out
the path of least resistance for him
and in which direction he's headed.
We don't know which power plant
to protect from him because shutting down
a power plants,
removing the nuclear fuel from the reactor itself.
The whole process can take seven years for the
whole area to be rendered inoperable and harmless.
Everyone panics knowing what's about to come.
They beg the Prime Minister
to let them fire at the creature.
And finally the Prime Minister announces
that they're clear to commence attack.
The command center declares the City of Kawasaki
a battle ground getting ready for all out war
ground forces begin gathering
and they're briefed on the radioactive
material present on Godzilla's head and two legs.
The choppers arrive on the scene
and they're given the order to fire instantly.
A barrage of bullets drill Godzilla in the face,
but it has no effect.
The chopper squad switches their ammo
to higher artillery bullets, but still nothing.
Godzilla pushes forward, getting closer to Tokyo,
the command center is shocked to see
that 16,000 bullets hasn't left a mark.
So they have the choppers take position
and fire missiles right at the creature's face.
A cloud of black smoke covers Godzilla,
but he emerges with no visible signs of damage.
Seeing this, the command center shifts
to phase two of their defense plant.
The ground tanks aim and all fire at the same
time, shooting their weapons onto its lower body.
And notice that Godzilla is slowing down.
They're on to something. On the count of three.
They commence artillery fire and engage
all forces onto the creatures
simultaneously,
and the command center moves on to phase three.
They launch an all out aerial assault,
bringing fighter jets into drop bombs from above.
The entire city shakes from the impact
and the jets continue to throw heavy fire
while Godzilla throws a part of the bridge into
the air, landing right next to the command center.
Suddenly it emerges from the debris
with seemingly no injuries.
The government decides that the best option
is to suspend operations.
The attack was a failure,
and Godzilla is still getting closer to Tokyo.
The officials begin
to realize that the Japanese Defense Force
is not strong enough
to take on the creature by itself.
They need outside help
and they decide to reach out to the U.S.
for aid, the U.S.
replies, instantly proposing a bombing zone
that will kill tens of thousands of civilians
instantly if they're not evacuated in time.
That's when one of the officials confronts
the prime minister
and tells him that he needs to leave now.
Godzilla is coming their way
and they need to get out of here.
Really, that's what we're going to do.
Japan's security treaty
with the U.S. has been in effect since the 1960s.
These two nations are committed to
defending each other if one of them is attacked.
The U.S. has over 20 U.S. military bases
located in and around Japan.
But this solution could be worse than dealing
with Godzilla ourselves.
The U.S.
wants to take him out with a couple of B-2
spirit bombers,
which is a heavy strategic bomber
designed at taking out anti-aircraft defenses
and is capable of delivering both conventional
and nuclear munitions.
This bomber, aside from nuclear munitions,
has the ability to hold up to £60,000
of explosives, which for scale in simple terms,
a bomb is often identifiable by its weight.
And even the simplest of bombs within the £2,000
range of explosives will usually carry around
about 940 ish pounds of some type of explosive
charge, ranging from TNT,
RDX and ammonium nitrate or something else.
The blast from a £2,000 charge will be enough
to carve a crater 50 feet across and around six
feet deep into the ground.
All of this from just a simple £2,000
explosive charge
and a single B-2 spirit bomber will be capable
of creating this much destruction times 30.
It won't be possible
to evacuate all the citizens in time,
which means their only option
is to have some sort of miracle
and survive in the Japan Metro Tunnel.
And the problem with that
is that most of the subway stations
simply won't work
due to the fact that they are shallow.
Most of the metros underground in Japan
do not surpass 30 meters deep.
This means that Japan is simply not prepared
for the creative destruction
and nuclear capabilities that Godzilla is capable
of, and neither will they be able to survive.
If those B-2 spirit bombers decide to rain down
hell on Godzilla and any sort of significant way,
dropping warheads onto a walking nuclear
reactor doesn't seem like a good plan.
It would decimate Japan.
Godzilla now in Megiddo City,
almost the doorstep to the heart of Tokyo, Yaguchi
and the others make their way out,
but the entire city is under gridlock.
They exit the car and hear bomb
like sounds in the distance.
The gigantic creatures footsteps are deafening.
Yaguchi's buddy tells them that the U.S. bomb
strikes are coming earlier than expected.
That's when the bombs hit.
And they watch as the U.S.
firepower causes massive leading to Godzilla.
The creature screams out in pain, and Yaguchi
notices that it's beginning to glow a purple hue.
No one has any idea what's going on when suddenly
it bends over and volcanic smog shoots
out of its mouth,
filling the city in a matter of seconds.
It sets the smog on fire and destroys
everything on the ground.
Godzilla lifts its head upwards,
turning its fiery breath into a terrifying beam
of light, demolishing the bomber from above
and two more bombers head towards it.
But Godzilla is done
firing more beams of light from its back.
It destroys the bombers
and the munitions they've dropped down
and continues to set the city on fire.
Yaguchi watches in awe and his buddy tells him
to head underground the next day.
The news reports that radiation has spread
throughout the entire city of Kawasaki and beyond.
The prime minister has gone missing, that they
need to find a replacement as soon as possible.
Yaguchi and his buddy walks into the new
government headquarters located in Tachigawa City.
He demands to know
the current location of Godzilla
and is told
that is currently inactive near Tokyo Station,
and the areas around the creature
are now highly contaminated,
making it impossible for anyone to get near it.
The Minister of Agriculture is announced
as the new prime minister.
Yaguchi gathers
the experts one last time, giving them a pep talk
and tells them that they must stop
the deadly creature
and gives them live samples of the creature
for research.
Kayoko arrives to inform them that other countries
would like to get involved in the fight.
Yaguchi meets with foreign experts
and they watch as a floating surveillance system
closes in a Godzilla but loses signal
before they can get a good look at the creature.
The foreign expert explains that
it may have something similar to a built in phase
radar, allowing it to intercept incoming objects.
This keeps getting worse and worse.
Godzilla has a built in radar.
That's a problem.
We as humans use faced array radar systems
for military and nonmilitary purposes.
The radar system was developed for use in military
radar systems,
steering a beam of radio waves into the sky
to quickly detect planes and missiles.
This explains
how Godzilla knew and was able to defend itself
when the military tried to attack it earlier.
Now, we also know that Godzilla
is not only capable
of releasing nuclear energy, but it's also leaking
nuclear waste wherever it goes.
At this point, aside
from what the government is trying to do to combat
Godzilla, what they need to figure out how to do
is to move him away from the city.
If Godzilla keeps leaking
nuclear waste all over Tokyo,
there won't be a city left to live in.
A group goes
and inspects the disaster zone and notices
the remains of Godzilla hanging from above.
The experts analyze it and find that the remains
are capable of becoming their own
living organisms. Yaguchi and Kayoko
meet up to discuss a very important matter.
The White House wants to use a giant nuclear
warhead to take out Godzilla.
If it isn't stopped, the creature might make its
way to American shores and become a global crisis.
Kayoko tells them
that the bomb they're going to use will be 75
times stronger than the one dropped on Hiroshima.
The prime minister tells his subordinates
that there's not much
they can do and asks them for permission
to go ahead with a nuclear strike.
His subordinates are shocked knowing that this
will affect Tokyo and Japan for decades to come.
The government gives the United States
the go ahead to vaporize Tokyo,
and the experts suggest
that there's only two choices
to make blow it up with a nuke
and suffer the consequences
or freeze it with a newly formulated drug.
However, creating this drug will require
672 kilometers of coagulation.
Yaguchi demands that they find a way
and they get to work,
and they call
all the chemical companies in the country
hoping to find a way to make this less
dangerous option work out.
The Prime Minister
and his subordinates meet again.
Breaking news about Godzilla.
In 15 days, the creature will move again,
and he'll be even deadlier than before.
Hearing this news,
the American government gives them a two week
grace period before dropping the bombs.
Now they have to evacuate 3.6 million people
from the Tokyo metropolitan area.
OK, Godzilla will resume activity in 15 days.
And the U.S.
is saying that Japan has two weeks to evacuate
3.6 million people from the area, are they not?
The resources and efforts
necessary will be immense.
And even then, where would they go?
You're going to need a huge amount of housing
and food to care for these people for a long time.
We need all modes of transportation, both military
and civilian, to take as many people as far away
from Tokyo as possible.
The U.S., since it's their great idea
to incinerate
all of Tokyo, have bases all over Japan,
and they can lend us their planes
and ships as well.
It's the least they can do
this bombs are going to drop on Tokyo is 75 times
stronger than the bomb little boy,
which was dropped on Hiroshima.
The death toll is going to be catastrophic
either way.
Moving millions of people is not easy.
The largest evacuation by a civil airliner,
for example, was the moving of 170,000 people
from Amman to Bombay during the Persian Gulf War.
And this evacuation took nearly two months.
We got two weeks.
Even if we're talking about the evacuation
within the country.
Places like Tokyo are going to be unable
to do this within two weeks, at least humanely,
unless some type of big international
military effort aid was given later on.
Jago, she continues to look at the intel about
the Japanese professor that knew about Godzilla.
The professor's wife died of radiation sickness,
so he made it his life's work to make radioactive
material harmless.
But they can't figure out the research
he left behind, wondering why there are lines
drawn all over it.
That's when the odor expert takes another
look at the origami
lying on the table
and realizes something extraordinary.
The experts get to work
figuring out that the professor's
research paper turns into a molecular chart
when folded like origami.
With the scientific details figured out,
they find that Godzilla can convert either
hydrogen or oxygen into the necessary molecules
to keep its body heated up and ready for action.
Using supercomputers, they solve the professor's
riddle and take a look at the scientific data.
They find out that the blood coagulation plan for
using Godzilla from the inside out is possible.
Yaku Cheese Buddy confronts
the Prime Minister, asking him to step aside
so they can try out the less deadly blood
coagulation plan.
The Prime Minister disagrees, telling them
that the US wants to get the issue over and done
with as soon as possible.
However, later, realizing that Yaguchi plan
will result in less death and destruction,
he changes his mind with two days left
until the grace period is over.
Yaguchi crew realizes that they need three days
to formulate the drugs.
Yaguchi and Kayoko make an agreement with Kayoko,
supplying whatever
weapons and equipment necessary
to undergo the coagulation plan with ours.
Until the creature reawakens Yaguchi gathers
troops and informs them
that they'll be heading to the disaster zone
where Godzilla awaits.
He warns them that some may not make it back
and that the future of Japan is in their hands.
OK, this is it.
It's the final countdown.
Godzilla is capable of rapidly evolving
to compensate and rid itself of any weaknesses.
And this is how the military hasn't
been able to defeat it yet.
Godzilla's blood and dorsal spikes
act as a natural cooling system for its body.
And this blood coagulant
that they're going to try and stick
Godzilla with will ideally interrupt his blood
cooling system
with the intent of freezing his body from within,
rendering him immobile, so to speak.
And while this plan does
seem to have some risk, it's
the only thing that we've got that won't redder
Japan and possibly the whole world unlivable.
The U.S.
plans to use a thermo nuclear bomb on Godzilla
that's 75
times stronger than the one dropped on Hiroshima.
And here's the thing.
The Americans seem to need to pound a nail with
a sledge hammer instead of just a regular hammer.
Common sense will tell us
that based on what we've seen as to
how Godzilla reacts to radiation,
one of two things will happen.
The bomb will drop and will either
make Godzilla thrive off of the nuclear blast,
resulting in this creature
having even more terrifying power,
or the bomb will cause Godzilla
to receive too much energy, making him unstable
and could result in everything around him
being in danger of radioactive poisoning.
Can you imagine detonating the world's
most powerful nuclear warhead weapon
on top of the world's most dangerous walking,
living, breathing nuclear reactor? Godzilla.
It's not going to end well.
And while this act may take down Godzilla,
it could take everything else down with it,
resulting in a nuclear meltdown of sorts,
the likes of which the world has never seen.
I'm just saying the smartest thing we could do
is to try the blood coagulation plan
and see if it works. Arriving at Tokyo,
they enact a curfew on the entire city
and put the coagulation plan into motion.
They send train cars to Godzilla's immobile body,
blowing them up and waking the sleeping beast.
That's when the Air Force arrives, dropping bombs.
But they're destroyed. By his laser beams.
But the planes keep on coming.
In order to waste its energy.
They then notice that the beams
have stopped discharging.
But then Godzilla shoots
laser beams from its tail and mouth
and suddenly the creature runs out of energy
and the laser beams stop Yakutsk.
His team blows up the buildings around it,
forcing it to fall to the ground.
They send out more missiles
to take out bigger buildings, burying Godzilla.
The Crane Platoon makes their entrance
and gathers around the creature's mouth
to administer pressure into its body. That's
when it wakes up and takes out the entire platoon.
But dogcatcher here has a backup plan.
He sends off more trained bombs
to hit the creature.
With the second and third crane platoons
arriving on the scene,
they finished administering the oxygen,
but Godzilla reawakens with killer intent.
Suddenly the creature freezes in place
and the mission is a success.
Later on, Yaguchi's subordinate
congratulates him on the gargantuan effort.
He informs him
that the entire cabinet is resigning,
meaning Japan will soon have another election
take place, with Yaguchi
having a strong case
to become the new prime minister.